Here's the equation for
computing the Sharpe ratio as
proposed by William Sharpe himself.
It's the expected value of the return
on a portfolio, minus the risk free
rate of return, divided by the standard
deviation of that same difference.
This is the ex ante formulation,
meaning, because we're using expected,
it's a forward looking measure of
what the Sharpe ratio should be.
Now to calculate this in reality,
we need to look back at those values.
So, for instance, the expected
value of this difference is just
simply the mean of what that
difference was over time.
So to calculate this in Python
using historical data, we just take
the mean of daily returns minus the
daily risk-free rate, and divide that
by the standard deviation of the daily
returns minus the daily risk-free rate.
Now you may be wondering,
what is this risk free rate?
Where can we get it?
Traditionally there are a few
numbers that people use for this.
One is LIBOR or
the London Interbank Offer Rate.
Another is the interest rate
on the 3-month Treasury bill.
And finally, a value that
people have been using a lot
over the last [LAUGH] few years is 0.
0 is a good approximation
to the risk free rate.
Now I've been presenting this as if
this risk free rate changes each day.
And indeed, LIBOR changes each day and
3-month T-bill changes
a little bit each day.
But there's a shortcut people use a lot
that simplifies this
equation significantly.
And this shortcut makes sense
because usually the risk free rate
is not given on a daily basis for, for
instance, putting your money in a bank
account or a certificate of deposit.
Usually that's a percentage on
an annual basis or a six month basis.
So you can convert that
annual amount into a daily
amount using this simple trick.
Let's suppose our risk free
rate is 10% per year or 0.1.
That means if we start at the beginning
of the year with a value of 1.0,
at the end of the year we have 1.1,
so we add 1 here.
So this is the total value of our
asset at the end of the year.
Now, what is the interest rate per
day that would enable us to get to
this value?
It's a number that if we multiple
it by itself each day for
each day in the trading year, or
252 times, would arrive at this number.
So here's how we do it.
We take the 252nd root of that sum,
believe it or not, that's pretty
easy to do in Python actually,
and subtract 1, and
that is our daily risk free rate.
We are, in most cases in this class,
just going to approximate the daily
risk free rate with 0, because that's
what it's been for such a long time.
Of course, it may be changing in the
future, so keep this shortcut in mind.
Now, suppose we want to use this value,
which is fine.
We would plug that in here,
and also plug it in here.
So observe that if we
plug a constant in here,
in this standard deviation calculation,
we can just remove it.
Because a set of values
minus a constant,
when you calculate the standard
deviation, is just as if this were 0.
Summing it all up, this is
the equation we typically use for
calculating Sharpe ratio
using daily returns.
We drop the daily risk free rate
from the standard deviation because
we treat that as a constant.
If our daily risk free rate is greater
than 0, then you need to plug it
in here, but we can usually
use a constant there as well.